Welcome to our short course in
economics where we learn how we
make choices when unlimited human wants
meet limited resources. Supply and demand
shows how people coordinate their decisions
by communicating through prices. “Supply”
refers to the number of goods and services
that sellers produce at a certain price.
“Demand” refers to how many goods and services
consumers are willing to buy at a certain price.
Let’s assume there is just one coffee shop
on the market, but 100 people who drink
coffee. The price of coffee is $3 per cup,
and the people each drink one cup per day.
We can illustrate this with a diagram
showing the price per cup of coffee on
the vertical axis and the number of cups
of coffee consumed on the horizontal axis.
At $3, 100 cups are demanded. What
do you think, how many cups of coffee
would these 100 people drink if the
price of a cup were to increase to $8?
While at $3, a 100 people drink a cup of
coffee, at $8, maybe just 30 do. And at $12,
there could be as few as 10 people
interested in purchasing a cup.
However, at $1 per cup, demand could go up to 150
cups a day, because some of those original 100
customers are now drinking two or more cups.
This is what economists call a demand curve.
It shows how much quantity is in demand at
each price. The curve usually slopes downward
because economists assume that the lower
the price the higher the quantity demanded.
The supply curve shows the number of goods or
services sellers are willing to provide at a
given price. It curves upward because
the higher the price, the more supply.
As we already know, at $1 the people on
the market demand 150 cups a day. However,
the owner already pays $1.20 for the beans per
cup. Which means, he can’t sell a cup for just $1.
If the price were to be $12 per cup, the
owner could hire two additional staff,
while supplying up to 150 cups. Unfortunately,
only 10 customers would buy at that price.
And that’s not enough to cover
the costs of the business.
The sweet spot happens to be $3. At this
cost, the owner can hire one employee and
happily supply the 100 cups a day
that are demanded at that price.
Supply and demand on one graph look like this:
At $12 the owner can supply 150 cups. But only 10
people would buy a cup of coffee at that price.
At 1 dollar he can’t supply any. But
demand would be at 150 cups of coffee.
The two curves meet at $3 and 100 cups.
Let’s now assume circumstances change.
The summer was very hot, and
there was only a little rain,
which left many coffee bean crops destroyed.
The poor harvest yielded a low supply of beans.
As a result, more traders bid for the limited
amount of beans, leading to an increase of price.
The shop owner now buys the beans from
the farmer at $2 for the beans per cup.
Can he still sell at $3? He tries
and decides to let go of his employee
and begins serving coffee all by himself.
But he cannot meet the demand of all
his customers. If the government were
to force him to keep the price fixed, as
some do through so-called price controls,
queuing would be part of everyone’s life.
To reduce the wait times for his clients and
make up for the increased cost of the beans,
the owner decides to increase
the price of the coffee to $4.5.
The supply curve now shifts to the left
and at $4.5, the shop will sell 70 cups
of coffee per day. Typically, the higher the
selling price of a good, the greater number of
people willing to supply it. This means that
there will likely be more competition soon.
In real life and within a free
market, if you drink coffee at $4.50,
it’s not the basis of an economic
calculation, but the result of an
endless dance of trial and error between sellers
and buyers that lead them to reach an unspoken
agreement about what works best for both. This
phenomenon is referred to as emergent order.
Before we summarize,
please note that economists differentiate
between “quantity demanded” and “demand”.
A change in the “quantity demanded”
happens due to a change in price,
like we explored when the price dropped
and the quantity demanded increased.
A “change in demand” happens when the
environment changes. Let’s imagine
that many people in the market become more
health-conscious and think that coffee is bad.
If that happens, the entire
demand curve shifts downward,
and at $3, not a hundred buy coffee but just 40.
Let’s summarize: Supply is the
amount provided at each price
Demand is the amount purchased at each price
The Final Price is the result of an emergent order
If you are up for it, we will now ask you to
help us understand today’s price of coffee.
Post your thoughts in the comments below!
Search for a Coffee Price Chart and you’ll find a
graph showing the price of coffee in US Dollars.
Then tell us: What's the price
of one kilogram of coffee today?
What do you think are the reasons that have
caused the price to fluctuate in the past 5 years?
This and all other Sprouts' videos are
licensed under the Creative Commons.
That means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms, online courses or
to start projects - and
today, thousands already do!
To learn how it works and download this
video without Ads or background music,
checkout our website or
read the description below.
If you want to support our
mission and help change education
visit our Patreon - that's patreon.com/sprouts.